quisiera destacar el hecho que el
presidente señaló que tanto la opción a
prueba como la opción rechazo son
opciones válidas para la
manifestación de preferencia de los
ciudadanos al momento del plebiscito del
4 de septiembre pero sin embargo en su
introducción que como decía la
corresponsal fue una con una instrucción
bastante larga pero también con carácter
aún bastante histórico en el fondo de
darle un contexto a esta cuenta pública
en el marco de la trayectoria histórica
del país señaló que este es
efectivamente un proceso muy relevante
para el país en un momento en que los
chilenos y chilenas van a poder elegir
si mantiene la constitución vigente que
la constitución que tuvo origen en 1980
en el régimen de pinochet con las
reformas posteriores o aprueban el
proyecto de constitución que es que se
presente al término del trabajo de la
convención constitucional que va a
suceder es muy difícil decirlo a él
ahora por supuesto hay una serie de
encuentros que manifiestan una
preferencia en uno o en otro sentido
pero de que estamos frente a un proceso
histórico en este sentido
sí porque porque en el fondo la
constitución de cierta forma va a dar el
marco cierto a la institucionalidad y
también va a suponer supuestamente va a
expresar todas las demandas que dieron
origen a este proceso que fueron las que
las que se manifestaron en el estadio
social esto se debiera haber cierta
sincronía cierto entonces en este
proyecto con un foco social muy fuerte
del presidente boris y esta nueva
constitución de llegarse a probar